hey everybody welcome to live-streaming
with Jessie today we're going to get
into some Redux which we set up
yesterday so if you want to see how how
you do the initial setup to incorporate
Redux into your react project check out
yesterday stream today we're gonna
figure out how we want to structure our
store so from what I understand you
should think about how you're going to
structure your store before you really
start building out everything for your
app so we're going to put some thought
into that at first the last time I did a
Redux project I didn't completely figure
out what I wanted to do with the store
and it ended up causing me to have to re
redo a bunch of stuff
probably like two or three times I
changed my mind on on how I wanted to do
that so I definitely caused more work in
the long run so I don't want to repeat
of that let's see I I think we'll do at
least two Pomodoro sessions of coding
today in between those we'll do a
five-minute session of question and
answer and then of course at the end
they'll answer all the rest of the
questions so if you're new to the stream
that's kind of the order that that we go
in and I know there's there's some stuff
going on today so I know Google's has
live stream stuff going on so not sure
how many people will want to watch this
stream when we have other stuff going on
there's a conference to going on that I
I see people on Instagram or posting a
lot of stuff from the conference but
it's like the women it's a women in tech
conference I can't remember what the
official name of it was but it looks
like a pretty big conference so not sure
if they're live-streaming but if so it's
possible okay so the Google stream just
ended
all right cool so we won't
competing with the google stream now for
those of you who watch the google stream
so this is going to be a somewhat
unrelated question here but I watched a
little bit of the stream you know the
stuff look cool I didn't get to see
everything for some reason the stream
just kept freezing for me
and so I missed a lot but I have a pixel
XL and it looks like I might be able to
get like $400 to trade in my pixel XL
and if I get a pixel 2xl it would cost a
little over $500 assuming that I got the
400 if I do the payment plan it might be
like somewhere around 20 25 US dollars
per month which is it's doable so what
do you think is it worth it now to
upgrade from the pixel XL to the pixel
to excel or should I just wait till next
year and keep this pixel for two years
before I trade it in so I was going to
just wait till next year but then I saw
how much I could get for the trade-in
and thought wow that's that's nice so
anyway I'm a little bit undecided right
now about it and it did sweeten the deal
a little bit that you get a free Google
home many I think that's what they're
calling it
if you do get the the pixel - so a
little added bonus but anyway I'm
undecided so so let me know ok so Cronus
says wait till Black Friday Rowland says
wait for next year William says just buy
it outright interesting so you think if
I buy it outright and then just try to
sell my my pixel my current pixel phone
I could get more money for it assuming
that's what that's why I would just buy
it outright I didn't think about that
but I'll have to see how much they go
for
okay so let's get all right so Rowan
thinks it's not really that big of an
upgrade yet yeah I really didn't didn't
think that there was that much that was
better with the phone yeah I don't know
I'll have to look into it more and see
if it's if it's better all right so
let's get started
yesterday I forgot to go over some of
the pool requests that we received so at
the end after we do the coding but at
the beginning that question and answer
session I'm gonna try to remember to go
over those let's see let's bring over
let's bring over our Pomodoro
and we have our yeah this is the right I
have quite a few terminals open but this
is yeah this is the right one okay great
let's see
not sure what I changed I got rid of
okay so I never committed that sorry
sorry that I didn't commit that stuff
let's see what did we do all right let
me start this first thing I'm gonna do
is commit some of this stuff to github
so you all can can check it out the link
to the github repository is in the
description for this video now so you'll
be able to see everything that working
on github also let's get Angra running
and let's see I have it yeah so I have
things going on on a terminal on another
window let me see what's three thousand
and one okay
all right so I'm going to paste into the
live chat the the link
so that link should work I will
double-check as well to make sure it's
working okay great so it is working yeah
it looks like I could see a lot of
activity there so if you're not familiar
with this this will allow you to see in
real time what's going on when we make
changes on your own computer and that
way you know you can open up dev tools
you can check things out this you won't
have I'm I'm not a hundred percent sure
about this but potentially let me try
this out you might even be able to use
the Redux Chrome extension and see if it
works
stay yeah okay so this actually works so
whenever we're creating our store you'll
be able to have access to this as well
so assuming that you that you get this
for Chrome and I don't remember what
it's called what did we call it in our
at redux dev tools extension all right
so I tried redoubts dev tools extension
and see if that's the name if it's not
let me know I could look up what the
name of it was officially so you can get
that but that will be really helpful to
understand what's going on with with
redux okay
so let me bring over I'm gonna run on
local 3,000 won okay so right now we
have the most basic of apps here but we
have a couple of routes in here we don't
have them length but if we typed it into
our address bar we could go to the other
routes let me commit and what did we do
the we added routes that's about what we
did okay so that code is now on github
now let's this thing about what we want
to do for our for a store so we'll need
to think about two things so one what
are we going to actually display to the
user you know what are we gonna do with
the data and then also what's the day
that looking like as it's coming in so
we're using WordPress as our content
management system and we're getting data
from the WordPress API so we can check
out how that data looks and let me find
let me bring up just some sample
WordPress API data hmm I know I have a
test
I'm pretty sure have a test WordPress
installation somewhere just for this so
let me do a quick check
oops I typed in the wrong address here
we go
I'm gonna pull it I'm doing this on my
other screen but I'll pull it over just
in a minute when I get the right thing
okay awesome
let me bring this over okay so here I
actually just pulled this off of my own
website which if you go there know that
I have not updated this for quite a
while so the actual design is five years
old maybe at least five years old the
content has been updated maybe maybe
like two and a half years ago and
nothing has happened since then so so be
kind if you comment on it but I do have
some some posts on there so this is what
the date is going to look like we can
change how this data comes in so if we
don't need every bit of this data we can
filter that out so this is just an
example of the basic data you'd get from
the WordPress API if you didn't have
anything else running but just the API
so no extra plugins no custom post types
so we're gonna get an array of objects
everything is going to have certainly
unique ID the dates those will probably
be important to us
the only other fields that we really
care about would be probably the status
right we don't want to pull in drafts
the slug we don't we're not worried
about the link we want to know the type
if we end up having custom post types we
definitely want to know what type it is
certainly the title and the content not
really worried about the excerpt maybe
we'll want that but I don't usually use
it
see we don't need the author we won't
need something with the featured media
but what I'll probably do is use a
plug-in so that we can get some better
data our categories and tags we will
need information on these but again I'll
probably use a plug-in so we get better
data right now we just get the number 43
all right so that means the category
with the ID 43 which isn't that helpful
I want to know what's the name of the
category what's the slug so we'll be
doing something different for that and
that's about it so a lot of this stuff
we won't even worry about but one thing
I would like to do once we get this data
in is when it's in the store I don't
want it just like this what I want it is
in the format of and the meeting I'll
make this smaller do I really only have
two posts I guess so
so what I want is to pull the ID so the
I assuming the ID numbers are all unique
which I'm pretty sure that that is the
case we can either use the ID or the
slug but for now let's just say we're
gonna use the ID so we'll have our array
and then we're gonna have key value
pairs where the ID becomes the key and
then the value is this object okay so
what that will allow us to do then is to
we'll have our posts in the store and
when when we want to pull in more posts
and merge those new posts in it will
check based on the ID and it will only
update it would only add those posts
that have a different ID or potentially
update the posts that have the same ID
and then we can keep the other stuff in
the
or we'll be able to reference those by
ID if we need to so that's the that's
basically the structure of the store
what I what I wanted to be structured
like we're probably going to run into
some other things like maybe we'll want
to add some data into here that isn't
that we can't get from WordPress so if
that happens you know we'll deal with
that when we get to it but first step is
just to bring this data in and then
change it to the format that we want so
for now I'm just going to use this data
from my own website and eventually we'll
probably want to bring in some data a
you know that's closer to what we're
actually going to use but this will work
for now so let's get this set up to
actually pull in some of the data we'll
need to
but you can make our API calls so let's
pull in let's make another folder so
another directory we're going to do this
in our source and we're gonna call this
leads and then we're gonna we're gonna
make a file in there it's gonna be let's
call this actually let me double check
I want I'd like to use the same naming
conventions that I've been using for my
previous read up project Redux project
just to make it consistent so I'm gonna
bring this up on my other screen and
github and if you want to check it out
that's the Udacity react and the
readable project on my github profile
which I'll just post the link into the
live chat so this will be an example of
the entire redux app that's already
finished and working so our app that
we're building won't look exactly like
this but it will share some elements
okay so let's go with those
okay so now that we have this all
everything that we're going to need to
get data from WordPress we're going to
put in here so that'll keep it separate
and it won't clutter up our other our
other files so let's go with there's
some words press I'm gonna exports let's
call this stretch pose
and we're gonna use fetch so if you're
not familiar with the fetch API this is
a way to make basically what you would
use Ajax for or some people use Axios
there's some other libraries I guess
that can do the same thing but fetch is
it's it's newer I mean it's been around
for a while but it's newer and I I like
using it I think it's very simple so
check it out if you if you haven't used
it yet you're definitely gonna see an
example of using it here and we've used
it for I think all of the projects that
we've needed to make an API call for
that we've worked on on this stream
we've used fetch for that so let's let's
get our URL and what I put that
I cannot find where I put the data I
losing my mind here I hope I didn't
there we go
here's alright so here is our data and
so we're just gonna grab that is that's
where we need to make the call - so
we're gonna fetch that and we shouldn't
need I don't think we need any headers
with this we'll try it without it if we
end up needing some I'll go back and
check out some of the code from a
previous project and just see how we did
it from on that project we should be
able to just go from here and then we're
gonna have our data and let's go
all right such a sum and that's it I
think that's all we need for right now
we may grab some some different things
here so this is probably not all we're
gonna do but this will work for now so
let's save that and then let's connect
this so we're going to connect this into
our actions so let's find some actions
as our reducers oh here I already had
the actions up so here's our actions so
what we'll do is we're gonna make C
we're gonna have to import what we had
just done here import
- from
eatos
okay so now we've imported this and then
right now we only have one export but
when you put this here that is just
going to bring in all the exports so
correct me if I'm wrong on that but
that's why we're just bringing it in I'm
anticipating possibly having more here
so I'm just going to do it like this
right off the bat okay so now I'm gonna
bring in let's make sure
let's go with
okay so we're bringing in the dispatch
because we're in it after we make the
API call we're gonna dispatch this
action so it'll be kind of a two-step
process so from our component we're
gonna dispatch this action that's why
we're exporting this then it's gonna
make the API call get the data and then
pass that data as posts into this action
when it dispatches that action okay and
then from here it's gonna go to the
reducers so that's what we're gonna do
so let's go what we call this post API
until and then we're gonna go fetch
posts right so from the post API util
we're calling fetch post and then we
don't need to pass anything right so
everything it needs is right here and
then let me go then then we want our
posts here and let's just
we're gonna dispatch get posts and we do
need to pass it our posts it's so
probably not formatted in the best way
but we'll get our Auto formatting and I
did not set up the plug-in and Adam to
do the formatting for me yet but when we
commit we'll get our formatting okay I
think that's everything I need let's
save it just see if we get any errors
yep we did okay import and body of
module reorder to the top okay so what
did I do I need to import at the top
okay
all right if that's our only error then
I'm fine with that okay great so now
that we have that done we actually need
to call this from from inside of a
component so let's go to our home our
home page and if you remember we took
out part of this here so we're gonna
need to put that back in so let me grab
it so I have it in another repository
I'm just going to copy and paste it from
there
okay so actually I'll type this out cuz
it'll be easier for me to explain it I
think if I if I type it it might be I
don't know I think it'd be easier to
comprehend if we go step by step instead
of me pasting a bunch of stuff in there
all at once so we're gonna go map
dispatch to props and then we can let's
use this here
all right so now we'll have dispatch
available in our props and then also I'm
gonna say fetch data and we're going to
let's see do we need to pass now we
don't eat we're not gonna pass anything
right now we're in a dispatch fetch post
and that's where we're gonna make that
that call now we need to import fetch
posts so let's bring that in oh actually
and I I did not I just commented that
out alright so now we can bring in fetch
posts from actions right so in our
actions we're exporting fetch posts and
on
let's see mounts uh this Frost
fetch fetch data okay so let's make sure
fetch data if it's David dispatch fetch
props fetch pose okay alright let's see
if this works
make sure I save these two and we'll
give it a shot alright what do we have
here this processed data is another
function what did I get wrong
oh okay I never brought in map dis
bastard props here so I didn't need to
bring this in as well
map dispatched across there we go let's
see alright great so now you don't have
the error let's check our store there we
go
cool so you can see under receive posts
we now have our data and this data can
be available to any component and so all
we have to do is since this is in the
stores you know just pull in our data we
can Mack state two props and and have
that available so we can even see so
within our component state yeah why is
react not turning on hmm so for some
reason area for some reason it wasn't
working when I was clicking on the
drop-down but let's go in here um if we
check out or so we have our dispatch a
fetch data where we got
as a tier where some states
I'm a machine
actually this is odd I should be able to
see the state around I should be able to
see it in props what am I missing here
okay maybe
it's
did I forget did I forget to start my
timer or did it go off and I didn't hear
it okay so I'm definitely gonna take I'm
gonna take my short break now new
question answer so sorry about that
obviously it's been longer than 25
minutes so alright so I'm gonna take a
break from that for just a second and if
it's not clear what I'm worried about is
I I expected to see something different
for props so maybe I'm just mistaken but
we'll check that out in a few minutes so
I'm going way up to the top of the live
chat I'm just gonna work my way down
look for questions or any comments that
you know pertaining to this part of the
project and then later on I'll go over
all the rest of it when we're done with
the coding portion
Skaar no asks are you going to write
tests I would like to write some tests
I'm not great with writing tests so I'm
gonna have to think about how I'd want
to write those what I'm gonna use and
then learn how to do it so so I'd like
to but I haven't made any decisions
regarding that yet Cronus says when we
use C++ for this project for this
project which is project for I'm not
going to be using C++ I for project 3
which will be going back to occasionally
we are using c-sharp
but I don't have any projects where I'm
currently using C++
let's see alright so Marco says hi Jesse
first time here
finally I catch you streaming greetings
from Brazil hey how's it going I noticed
you had a comment on the last video
saying that you never get to catch the
live stream so really glad that you
could be involved in the live stream
today so feel free to ask any questions
or you know throw your opinion in in
there in the live chat si all right so
I'm not gonna read this person's name so
they don't get in any legal trouble but
someone keeps asking how to hack a
facebook account without a phishing page
I am NOT going to answer that question
so normally I answer any questions but
that that question seems like the type
of question that will not lead to
anything good so so sorry about that but
we're not going to talk about hacking
Facebook pages on this stream
so if you do want to stick around to the
person that's talking about hacking
Facebook pages if you do want to stick
around watch the stream ask some other
questions not related to hacking that's
awesome
if if you keep asking the hacking
question over and over again then I
don't want to maybe I'll block I don't
know it depends if there's a huge wall
of questions then maybe it would be too
much but it looks like as I'm scrolling
down there's not a lot of questions
we'll see okay nice or asked is your
asp.net core project three for beginners
I see a lot of complication in that
project some of that project is
definitely could be for beginners it's
just you know kind of basic just
building a layout HTML CSS the parts of
the project where we're actually going
through some of the c-sharp and trying
to build out the templates could be a
little bit more complicated it just
depends on your background I guess but I
have I have a different approach to that
project that so the next time we do a
stream for project three I'll introduce
kind of my new approach that will allow
it to be a little bit more interactive
and allow me to accept full requests and
things so so maybe that'll make it a
little bit more beginner friendly
hopefully it will all right
so jonbi loves the minimal design so far
home this is the home page yeah I just
want to be user-friendly and as
straightforward as possible so I didn't
want there to be any confusion that
that's the home page all right
david says where are you from Jessie I
guess South actually so right now I'm in
Steubenville Ohio but I grew up in West
Virginia but probably not the type of
West Virginia that you think of when you
think of stereotypical West Virginia so
I grew up in the most northern part of
West Virginia which is actually about 20
minutes away from Pittsburgh it's right
there on the same latitude of Pittsburgh
so anyway so that's where I'm Betsy I'm
from actually the city where I'm from
according to Jeopardy at Alex Trebek is
the only city in the United States that
borders two different states so the part
of the city that I lived in the end of
my street was Pennsylvania and then the
other side of the city borders the Ohio
River and of course the state of Ohio so
anyway I could at one point I could walk
in my backyard and and go into
Pennsylvania right through my backyard
so I always thought that was kind of
cool I used to stand on that spot and
say like I'm in between states anyway
but that's around froth
let me see my huh my time I went off I
for some reason it's not beeping it used
to beep in my I could hear in my
headphones so I'm just gonna have to
make sure I keep checking this because
I'm not getting that that beeping sound
I'm gonna refresh just see if it helps
okay let's see I'm gonna come back
I did notice Williams says nice about
page photo I don't remember what photo
that is I'm gonna check it on my other
screen and quickly cuz now I wonder what
picture I have on there oh man that's
what I had my hair longer I need to
change that so I'm not gonna show that
on the stream you're welcome to look it
up if you want but uh huh
I need I need to do something else with
that site okay so back to coding to
restart our timer and
alright let me think
what is
Cephas
okay that makes sense
Steve
see this was that my problem
hmm
there we go okay now we have it so now
you can see in the props for home
we have posts and that's because we
brought in here this part of the state
right receive post as posts okay so the
problem there was just that I had the
wrong the wrong word there okay great so
we're bringing this data in now at this
point we could display it you know on
the page but I want to change the
structure of it so there's really no
point in doing anything to display it
right now because that that wouldn't
worry I just I just check the live chat
and it looks like a few of you have have
checked out that photo so
let's see
okay
so let's in our reducers we're so
reducers here we go all right so we're
gonna handle restructuring things in our
reducers so if if you're checking out
the other github repo that I'm getting a
lot of these examples from you can check
out the reducers now and that's where
I'm going to get some some of the basic
meal code from to do this
okay so right now you can see we have
our posts and it's just it's just in an
array right so we have 0 and 1 and then
our objects as I said earlier instead of
the 0 & 1 what I really want is to have
the basically change this into an object
with key value pairs okay so here's what
I'm gonna do to make that happen
so within our reducers I'm gonna make a
little helper function now I'm not sure
if this is the best place to put this if
it might be better to make this a
separate component but for now I'm gonna
put it in here and we can you know later
on think about whether or not we want to
put it in a different component okay so
I'm just gonna call this function make
object because that's basically what
it's gonna do it's gonna take it and
it's its form as an array all right
we're going to turn it into an object
and we're gonna bring in our items so
for now it's gonna be post but
potentially we could do this with
anything so just kind of generically
we'll call it items and we're gonna make
a new object and we're just gonna set
that to be an empty object for now and
then I'm just going to do a really
simple for loop there might be a better
way to do it that probably is but for
loops easy to understand it's easy for
me and probably easy for a lot of the
people watching I know before I got
better with some of the newer Java
scripts a lot of the tutorials that I
read that used the newer stuff were very
confusing because of just the newer
syntax the concepts I think would have
been a lot easier to get if it weren't
for the newer syntax so ideal usually
the newer syntax for a lot of things
but in this case hopefully it makes it a
little bit more user friendly okay
so basic loop we're going to grab our
items we want items dot length I could
remember items is coming in as an array
yeah and we're just gonna go through the
items okay so we did use let's so if
you're not familiar with that we're
using let in constant set of variables
so instead of you know var right we're
using constant this is a constant and
then let now I'm not gonna go into
everything about these but basically you
make a constant and you try to mutate
that constant later on you're going to
get an error for the most part with let
you can change what let is obviously but
its scoped that it's block scoped right
so I could use let here and then I could
use let in another for loop right I
could use or I'm sorry I could use let I
equals whatever in a lot of different
places since it's block scoped it would
be fine I don't have to come up with
different variables for iterators I mean
that's not the main reason why you would
use let but in this case I think it's
just kind of an easy way to kind of show
the block scoping alright so within this
for loop we're gonna do I'm gonna make
some more constants
if you're not sure about Wendy use cost
and when do you slet generally of from
my experience and from what I've been
told from others you should pretty much
use cost by default and then you only
use let if you really need to use let
let's see okay so we have our items so
we're gonna grab the ID equals
I don't I D whoa it's not what I wanted
I'd be alright so we're not finished yet
but just so far to show so we're
iterating over these so we're getting
our items so for this particular you
know for each particular run through
this loop our item is just going to be
that that item or the at that position
in the array they were going to grab our
ID I'll do want to double check in the
data structure
I think it's ID but let's double check
so that doesn't cause problems yeah
ID okay so we're gonna grab the ID which
for our first one will be 772 then what
we want to do is get our new object and
we're gonna go item ID equals item right
so here's what we're doing so I don't
want to confuse anyone so we made this
constant right and I just said that you
can't mutate a constant but in this case
if we're adding things to an object
that's a constant right that's that will
work but I couldn't say new object
equals a string called
called what it called string right and
then down here say a new object equals
five okay that did we get an error on
that alright so then our new object
needs to be returned so what this will
do is take well I'll show you let me
show you the data and then it'll be
obvious what it does so let's save that
and let's call this from inside our
receive posts so instead of merging the
state with just action dot posts which
is just the data we're getting in from
the API we're gonna change that data a
little bit by merging it
what we get returned from make objects
so let's say that now now let's check
out our store there we go so you see the
difference now so now we have our object
right this is no longer an array this is
an object with key value pairs and our
keys are the IDS and then the value is
all the rest of the the data for that
item okay and then so now that you've
seen it you can tell right that's that's
just what we've done right we broke it
down that that array and instead we've
made in an object with the ID right as
the key and then everything else as the
value okay now here's here's the thing
this is going to be actually I guess
some stuff coming alive chat so let's
see a shorter version
okay cool so kevin is typing out in the
live chat a shorter version so let's go
ahead and refactor this right now for
the shorter version so hopefully you
kind of understood what was going on
here it may or may not be easier to
understand it once we refactor so let's
do that now okay so in our for loop
we're going to use a for loop okay so
it's going to be for item
okay so our four of loop is we're just
making whatever we can this could be
whatever we want to call it okay but
we're calling it item of and then we're
pulling in our items array here so for
item of items so within here item is
gonna basically be that the same thing
as it was before but that's a little bit
of a shorter way to write that that for
loop and I would say honestly if you
were just starting out I think this
makes more sense in terms of explaining
what's happening then then the other way
we did the for loop with the iterator
all right and we're gonna shorten this
up by saying new object item ID let's
see
so we can get rid of this right because
now we've taken care of it up here and
then we can also get rid of this because
we've moved it down to here so a lot
shorter so let's save that and then it
works
yeah all right cool
cool okay thank you Kevin
definitely definitely shorter and more
concise is usually almost always better
alright great so now that we have that
let's um let me check how much time we
have okay ten minutes okay not bad let's
actually get some of this onto the page
so as much as this design now is is
amazing in minimal I think it might be
more helpful to the users if we
displayed a bit more information I don't
know about you but I don't know how many
times I would come back to this page you
know I just probably could remember that
this is the home page so we're gonna put
some more info on there now let's go to
our home page and we're going to make a
more proper return so we're going to eat
we're gonna use the old-school way of
returning not this newfangled react 16
way so oh wow did Sebastian typed up an
even shorter way of doing this all right
let me copy and paste this alright let's
check out Sebastian's
even shorter way and I will I'm gonna
paste this in right above at first just
so we can compare okay
so here we go so we have cost make
object and we're using an arrow function
so we're passing in items and then we
have our new object we're mapping over
our items
and then we're making our key value
pairs and returning the new objects so
let me see is that really is that really
shorter let's uh let's break this down a
bit just to compare if this would really
be that much shorter so how would I
normally do this new objects
yeah I guess that's how I would break
this up
okay
all right so once I space this out it
actually ends up being the same amount
of lines all right so let's see I'm
gonna move on from this because I mean I
like this this is cool but we're gonna
run out of time and not be able to
display any data so yeah so map would
normally be able to auto return these so
do we even need well I guess right we
don't want to we don't want to just
return this each time
I mean as as the Kim the entire thing
all right I'll let you all discuss it
discuss this in more depth for now
let's comment one of them out so that we
can work on this all right five minutes
six minutes almost okay so let's let's
bring in
okay so we're already getting we know
we're already getting the data in here
it's getting passed in as props post and
let's
hmm
all right so first thing we're gonna do
is let's make a div just to be a
container and then within there we're
going to map let's give this propos'd
and so we're gonna check if if this
props posts is is there then we're gonna
do is go objects okay so I'm gonna this
is gonna seem weird but we're gonna
change this back into an array because I
want to be able to use map and filter
and sort on this so we're gonna change
this back and then we're gonna filter
actually do we need to filter right now
now I mean at some point we will be
filtering these but right now I don't
think we need to worry about that so
let's go Matt hose
most and within here for now let's just
do an h1 and we'll give it a key of post
dot dot ID and then we're gonna put in
the post dot title rendered okay so that
rendered isn't anything special that's
just the way the data is organized in
WordPress
let's try that out it should work
No what'd I do wrong let's check it out
hmm
nothing I already yes
oops posts that's the problem
yeah that's it all right so you can see
that the only problem was I
I forgot the s on the end so first it
was checking if this props post exists
and that doesn't exist right so there we
go okay cool so now we can see we're
able to use map and we could also use
filter and sort which i think is a lot
easier to work with which is the whole
reason for this for changing this so
that we can work with it here now we
have our titles and actually I wonder
I wonder if I could just display
I can't cattle I there's got to be some
way to turn this into the string isn't
it like stringify something I see sorry
I didn't check out the live chat you all
saw ahead of time what what the problem
was let's see
so I could do
let's see if that'll give us something
all right cool
okay so this looks really ugly but just
to show you we're just trying to show
you what what comes out here and in
terms of what's getting passed so I
still have thought about it I always get
nice formatting because I have this
plugin with JSON so now this is pretty
much unreadable but anyway let's get
back to something we're readable okay
I'm pretty sure I've used up my time for
that Pomodoro session
I've lost my where my head
I'm getting something from
what did I do okay
I didn't go back far enough there we go
all right and there yeah so my timer is
up so I'm gonna go to the live chat and
let's see I'm gonna scroll back up to
where I left off and if if you can't
stick around for the question answer
session I totally understand but if you
can if you have some time I'd love it if
you could help answer some questions or
ask some questions of your own but
otherwise thanks for watching and I'll
be back again tomorrow probably around 2
p.m. Eastern Time
so let's go or I'll be left alright so
I'm just going to go down through the
list and answer hopefully have time to
answer all the questions I know
yesterday I had to cut it off you know
pretty quickly when I got to the bottom
of the questions but today I haven't
gotten any messages from my boss so I
should be okay let's see
it's about Paige all right there's some
some more comments on my about page
photo ok so John BS he Jumby says I
haven't worked with redux myself before
what is the slug supposed to be the slug
isn't a Redux thing okay and it's like
William already answered so it's a
wordpress thing yeah so the in WordPress
normally I well there's several
different ways you can have the URLs
display but the best I think the best
way to do it is have the slug be part of
the URL
so whatever the slug is for that post
ends up being what's after the slash and
your URL and it's it's also unique
identifier for for the posts and pages
have their own slugs - I've had some
requests to speak Hindi unfortunately I
cannot speak Hindi so apologize for that
although if someone would like to
translate these streams into Hindi and
have them available as captions that
would be awesome
that would probably be a lot of work but
it would be a good way to contribute to
free code camp so if you're interested
that's that's definitely an area where
where we need more volunteers
not just for Hindi but for any any
language
all right
okay John Hanson asks if fetch is
supported on all current browsers I
think actually I haven't even checked I
always use a polyfill so I can't answer
that that question because it doesn't
really matter to me because I use the
polyfill so that's what my
recommendation anyway if you're going to
use fetch use a polyfill with it and and
then you have to worry about it but I do
think browsers are I'm pretty sure
chrome can handle fetch but I guess it's
worth checking it might be good to know
and here we go if you're not familiar
with can I use calm definitely a good
site to memorize that URL it's really
easy can I use calm and then you just
type in whatever thing you're trying to
use whether it be in JavaScript or CSS
and you'll immediately get this chart so
we can see if you want to use fetch
obviously ie11 doesn't support it
because it doesn't support anything edge
Firefox Chrome Safari Opera iOS Safari
even while Android Chrome for Android so
basically it will work except for Opera
Mini and Internet Explorer 11 and it has
been supported even in previous versions
of Safari and Chrome and Firefox so
awesome so evidently chrome is or fetch
is pretty usable right now it certainly
depends on what you need to support them
let's see
William a little while back said we'd
love to continue watching but it's
meeting time so probably not watching
right now but good luck with the meeting
and thanks for watching and contributing
in the live chat Kevin I'm so sorry so I
just read a few comments after the
original question about fetch Kevin said
for compatibility questions Google can I
use and then the feature name so anyway
so sorry Kevin that I just tried to tell
everybody about this when you already
had so Kevin was on top of things that
Marco says Axios or fetch which is best
for big JSON files I I'd never used
Axios so I don't know but Roland says go
with Axios if you want backwards
compatibility otherwise fetch is good
jonbi says you might want to chain
another dot then method to catch any
errors in the event that the fetch
request fails to retrieve the data okay
yeah that's that's a good idea
Jumby so what wolf to add that and I'm
not gonna go back right now but yeah
definitely normally you wouldn't want to
like if for something that's in
production you do want to catch errors
so he's talking about here when we did
our fats we would want to add in another
then and then catch errors like that and
possibly you know do something with the
error right when you display a message
or whatever however you want to handle
that
there's actually there's I've seen some
interesting ways to handle errors when
fetching data with with Redux so maybe
for the next stream I'm gonna look up
some of that and we can implement
something something like that Marco says
I'm developing my portfolio right now I
was using pre-act and that's frustrating
so I decided to use react instead react
is a good choice for something like
Israel is react a good choice or
something like a small portfolio Relan
says that react is probably overkill for
small websites it doesn't mean you can't
do it if you're comfortable react go for
it so yeah yeah it depends on what
you're doing in your portfolio site hmm
so I I look tired yeah it depends on I
guess on what you're doing I mean a
portfolio site could be really simple
one page thing or it I mean some
people's portfolios are amazing you know
they're like a work of art and they
you're displaying their skills right so
I wouldn't say right off the bat Reax
overkill for a portfolio because it
entirely depends on what you're trying
to do with your portfolio if you want to
market yourself as a react developer why
not do your portfolio and react then
your portfolio itself is going to be
evidence of your skills at reacts even
if it's overkill right so or if you want
to learn react if you're trying to get
better with react then yeah make your
portfolio with react it will it be
overkill probably but it'll get you
practice with something that's kind of
simple just to get you used to using
your
so if the question is simply is it
overkill the answer is probably yes but
if the question is should I use it then
yeah I mean I would say there's nothing
wrong with with using it if you want to
if that's what you want to do if that's
what you want to learn
let's see okay so Kevin says is an
alternative next j/s is an easy way to
set up a site with react yeah definitely
I definitely recommend that so one good
thing about next is you don't have to
worry about routing so if you're just
doing a very simple site you didn't need
any custom stuff going on and in the
backend then you just have as a code
your views folder I think maybe it's the
pages folder so anyway there's a folder
that you use a next and any components
you put in that folder automatically
it'll route to those so it takes care of
routing for you
it takes care of server-side rendering
for you so it handles a lot of things
you know like right now we're using
react router and we're handing in our
routing now it's not hard but that's
just one extra thing that you have to
learn so if you're just starting out and
it's something simple next is probably
the way to go because it handles so many
things for you it's much easier to learn
I think with next create react app is
also pretty easy to learn but it doesn't
do quite as much for you as next does
okay Blake says in response to the same
question here just go with plain
bootstrap in HTML you're just building a
portfolio by doing so you'll save a lot
of time for another bigger project with
react okay that's that's another
viewpoint I hadn't even thought of yes
so if if you just want to move on to
make something really cool with react
then maybe you just throw together that
portfolio with the basic tools write
HTML bootstrap or something like
bootstrap yeah and then do something
else with react so I get kind of does
depend on how much time you want to put
into this as well Rowen says I support
going with vanilla JavaScript and add
libraries to the project if you need
them view if you really want to play
with a framework okay also when we use
the term vanilla JavaScript I know most
of you probably know what that means but
I saw I don't remember if it's a comment
on a video or something but I saw
somewhere where someone didn't know what
vanilla JavaScript meant so just in case
I want to explain that so vanilla
JavaScript just means regular plain
JavaScript with no other frameworks or
libraries added in so it's as then like
vanilla is usually seen as like the
plain I mean even though technically
Benelli is a flavor right it's plain so
like vanilla ice cream is plain alright
it's it's not chocolate or you know like
rocky road ice cream yourself you know
it's just the plain so that's what I
mean by vanilla JavaScript let's see
Leon says how how do you get posts in
your component you didn't pass it to the
store through the reducer or did I miss
something okay let me let me see so
let me just walk through some of these
steps just an answer to this question
just to show what what happened so so
let's start out with at home so in our
component here in our home component
when the component mounts were fetching
the data all right so we're dispatching
this action to fetch posts let's go to
our actions now so oops it's our reduces
our actions are over here so fetch posts
makes the API call here this API call
returns our data all right and then all
right we're returning you know data to
JSON ultimately so that gets out here so
that's what goes in here to this then as
posts so this that is getting passed on
its dispatching get posts so now that
data the post data goes here from here
this is where I serve reducers okay our
reducers take over and then in so we're
bringing in get posts from actions
so when get posts is past then it's also
passing in all that post data right from
here and we're passing that through of
course our make object function and
returning our new object with our key
value pairs that gets merged with
whatever was in the state so this is
what ends up going into the store and
now we go back to the home component and
now whatever was in the store as receive
posts now becomes posts in our props for
this component so that's basically the
flow is there other stuff going on
behind the scenes yeah definitely but we
don't have to worry about that because
Redux takes care of that for us
so hopefully that was somewhat
intelligible I don't know that I'm the
best person to explain that but
hopefully that helped let's see uh gto
says will man stop being rude to people
let them be was I being rude I don't see
anybody in the comments that was being
rude so maybe I was being rude let me
know if I was I'm sorry uh let's see
yes een says how much javascript should
I know to learn any JavaScript framework
Oh
I honestly if we want to take framework
loosely and just include like any
framework like thing or library which I
don't want to get into beta for
framework versus library now but let's
just say you could use jQuery without
knowing very much at all about
JavaScript it's really easy if you
wanted to get something into something a
little bit more advanced like react or
angular I would say you'd have to have
more knowledge about JavaScript but I
don't think that you should wait to
become a JavaScript expert before you
move into a framework because they can
handle so many things for you that
there's really not there's value I guess
in knowing how to do it but it's it's
almost like a waste of effort to try to
redo things in vanilla JavaScript that
are already being done really well and
have been tested thoroughly by you know
in frameworks so I think at some point
you learn the basics of JavaScript and
then move into a framework and then
continue to build up your knowledge of
JavaScript as you do you do things right
so I I was looking back at our project
one and some of the code for that
earlier I was making some updates to it
and just looking at that already and
that's only been you know a few months
ago already my knowledge of JavaScript
has increased so much but I've been
building everything in react so yes I've
been using reacts but my JavaScript has
gotten better as a result so you know
you can do both you can build up your
skills in JavaScript while you're using
framework
a library so I'd say like if you get to
the point where you understand enough
JavaScript to be able to understand how
to use the framework then go for it just
remember that frameworks come and go so
don't stop improving your JavaScript
because that's what will get you through
you know the shifting of frameworks and
you'll be able to keep up with things
better i josh says Ohi all right
maybe josh is from ohio as well yeah so
although I live in Ohio now I am still a
mountaineer at heart so from west west
virginians the the one like big college
football team in the state of West
Virginia's mascot is a mountaineer so
that's why I say I'm a mountaineer at
hearts okay
Rohan says that is a nice photo the the
photo of my on my website Blake says
lovely photo Sebastian says yep great
photo Kevin likes it too thanks
everybody thanks I don't know I think I
look kind of silly with my hair long but
oh well
jonbi said I think your phone is ringing
my phone was ringing but I think it was
a spam caller so if anyone ever tries to
call me leave a message because I never
answered my phone unless I know who it
is because I just get so many spam
callers so like it's just it's a waste
of time to keep answering their phone
that's John be said for the home page to
make it a giant heart image because home
is where the heart is that's a good idea
maybe we'll throw that in okay he had
some discussion over the best way to do
that make object function that we had in
our in our reducers so I'm gonna skip
over that although that was a good
discussion but let's see I think it
would be hard to understand if I just
try to read out all the code that's
being posted for that
see
so what a lot of discussions still about
that so I'm scrolling down I'm looking
for another question
okay so Matt set for the API call you
can use async/await instead of then okay
cool
so yeah Matt if you're still watching
look into a sink away okay so I see your
further comments on that all right I'll
have to look into that
so in general is is async await a better
way to do this then then then so if
anybody has any opinion on that let me
know I'll definitely check that out I'd
like to do it the most efficient way I
can
Marko's asks if i'm using material UI or
something like that i will be using the
tear UI for this project so I haven't
decided yet whether I'm going to use the
newer version of material UI or the
older version we'll see if you remember
for our last project at the beginning
they just came out with material UI and
we tried to use it on like the first day
it came out or at least the first week
and had some trouble with it and
switched back to the old version so I
don't know well that's yet to be decided
but we're definitely going to use
material UI in some form
let's see
okay so jumpy says if I use
json.stringify
and then I would have done post common
okoma - it would indent the JSON values
by two spaces and it would be more
readable cool I didn't know that awesome
I mean I don't usually have to use json
stringify to display stuff but that's
that's really good to know for what I do
so deep says how do i code the minimax
algorithm for tic-tac-toe I mean I
understand the concept of having trouble
coding any tips
I haven't actually worked on that one
myself so I can't help you out i watch
the video on it if you're not familiar
with that so Bo did a video on making a
tic-tac-toe game in JavaScript so it
sits here on the free code camp so I I
haven't tried to get myself so I don't
know that I can answer that maybe if
anyone else in the live chat now has has
worked on that you know maybe maybe you
could add something here in the chat
should come with us is this playlist a
little more advanced than playlist - let
me think what was play this - what
projects was that the Resource Center
yeah hmm
yeah this is going to be a little more
advanced only because we're using redux
so it's going to see more advanced but I
think it's gonna help it's going to help
us a lot more with with handling our
data so if you remember in project one
we were making similar API calls to
WordPress so it's going to be a nice
comparison to see basically to make a
similar app using in the first case in
project one not not using Redux we use
next to bootstrap the project and then
instead in this project we're still
going to be making the same API calls
doing a lot of the same things with the
data but we're going to use Redux and
then we've also used create react app or
use react router so it's going to be
doing this
it's very similar things both using
react but in two different ways of using
react so I think it'll be cool it'll be
a nice comparison
piloff says just want to say thank you
so much if you drop by India and New
Delhi let me know I will be more than
happy to treat you for all the effort oh
that's awesome thank you so much
cool so I don't have any plans to go to
India right now but you never know maybe
I'll see if there's any conferences
JavaScript conferences in India and
maybe all apply to speak there I've
actually never been outside of my own
country so that would be it would be
cool India would most definitely be the
farthest away I've ever been see oh also
I did want to mention it I think I
mentioned this last week at some point
but I will be in Nashville Tennessee
here in the United States at the end of
November I think it's November 27th and
28th so if any of you are in that area
let me know if you if you'd like to meet
up you know somewhere and that that
would be cool I'm gonna go to the
November conference that's going to be
in in Nashville so if you can make it to
the conference that would be cool as
well but I'll only be there for maybe
like two or three days so we won't have
a lot of time but it but it would be
cool if anybody's interested let me know
birdperson says hello hi campers how you
doing Jesse not bad not bad so it was
somewhat productive today so that's
always good
nice are says what CSS framework are you
going to use let's try Bulma I was
actually going to use material UI so I
know I just said that and I know you'd
asked the question before I mentioned
that so I've never used one before I've
heard it's been recommended before in
the live chat so actually I don't know
let me know is is boom ah does it play
nice with reacts I'm gonna look this up
right now
okay all right so it looks like it's
it's like bootstrap interesting okay so
yeah actually Bouma looks really cool
but I for this project I'm gonna go with
materiai especially because we're gonna
want to keep the same user interface as
basically what we're gonna replace so we
already have a bulletin site that is in
use right now and it's going to be
replaced with what we build right now
but I'd like to keep a similar UI and
it's already using material design style
so it'd be much easier to recreate that
if we go with material UI but I'll keep
bulla in mind for a future project
especially maybe for a side project for
projects for the university that I work
for which these are the projects that I
always stream I'd like to keep things a
little bit more consistent to make it
easier for not just for me but for other
people who might have to come in and
work on these projects like if we hired
new people on or if some happens to me
and they replace me I think would be
easier to have more consistency with
things but I'm open to trying out new
things when I can see
all right so so back sebastien basically
just explained what I just said so he
said all the websites for the university
that he works for fall is material
design guidelines see how that's Therese
but if any then Sebastian added at least
the new ones the old websites are a mess
I'm not gonna argue with the old
websites are there was no consistency at
all in the design and I don't know I'm
not gonna say anything else but that's
the nicest way I could say it is that
there there wasn't consistency let's see
okay david says for catching errors in
the fetch it would be better to use dot
catch instead of dot then okay cool I
have to check that out
okay so Kevin says that it using
async/await is generally better to use
with fetch so okay okay so Marco says
there is a project that reacted boom ah
you I so okay so we could try that for a
react project so like I said for this
one we need to go with material design
but you know potentially for other
projects we could switch it up and try
that out so thanks for letting me know
about that Marco and also Nasir I think
it was yet nice our mentioned that as
well earlier in the stream okay cool so
Kevin has put some code in there for the
to use async async await with our fetch
so thanks for that Kevin let's try that
after the stream depending on what time
it is yeah I might I'll probably have
time see alright and Matt says don't
forget the catch okay cool I've gotten
to the bottom of the live chat so gonna
end things now if anybody has any other
questions outside of the live chat in
the livestream time we have a slack
Channel and I don't remember
I think the slack Channel we have we
have a link to that in the description
otherwise let me know send me a message
or something and I can send you the link
so we have a slack channel you can send
me messages on Twitter or any other
social media platform and of course you
can put comments to the videos you can
you can certainly put issues and all the
github repo submit pull requests if you
would like and use any of the repos you
want take take any of the code and use
it on your own projects so
does this lack Oh Marcus says the slack
doesn't work the link for slack doesn't
work okay I'll have to look into that
thanks for letting me know
I'll check into the slack to see what
what the problem is
okay cool I'll have to get a better
lengthen so yeah I didn't know so I'll
work on that
I'll do that right now before I forget
so as soon as I end the stream I'll
check out what's going on with that link
and try to get an actual working link in
there for the slack channel all right so
thanks everybody for watching and have a
lot of activity in the live chat which
is awesome it's always it's always great
when everybody's helping each other out
and let's see I will be back tomorrow
I'm just checking my calendar quickly
cuz I don't I don't think I've checked
my calendar at all yet today and yeah I
think I'm free tomorrow afternoon
so probably 2 p.m. eastern time tomorrow
we'll be back I'm thinking we'll
probably work on this project again
unless something else comes up that I
really need to work on or I think will
be interesting we'll be right back on
this doing some more stuff with with
redux and maybe we'll bring in some UI
components from a tier or UI as well all
right so I'll see you all tomorrow until
then have a great day